but we turn to the phone lines the
mercedes-benz van phone line the
reigning coach of the year from the
tennessee titans back here on the rich
eisen show coach mike vrabel how you
doing coach doing great how are you guys
i'm doing great as well uh better for
talking to you uh are you a golfer at
all do you play golf yeah i enjoy it
yeah i enjoy the uh
i'm not very good i'm very inconsistent
but uh yeah i enjoy the the things that
go along with golf
[Laughter]
walking the course is that what you mean
don't you talk about everything just the
whole you know just the whole process
swing oil little swing oil around the
nine around the turn lube action all
those things
i like it very much
uh okay let's uh let's talk about what
action might be going on in your world
how how does how does one prepare for
the 26th overall pick in the draft can
you walk me through that one
uh
yeah i mean i think you have to do some
stock into
you know we've taken some guys that um
have been injured
you know the last couple years
who we felt like were
wouldn't have been there had they um
not sustained injury you know with
jeffrey simmons and and caleb farley so
you do some work on on those guys um
that that may be there
um
you know i think you pretty much you
know i mean you do the entire board but
then you start to try to look and
you know target
you know a handful of guys that you
think will will be around that you never
can really predict it but right you kind
of figure out
who's who could be available and
you know sometimes some guys you know
slip for for obvious reasons or you like
somebody better than somebody else does
so you game it out are you like gonna
like actually have mock drafts and
things of that nature uh
we will yeah i mean as we get closer to
the process those are things that we've
done
uh in the past you know had had
different picks come off in different
scenarios okay um what's it like um
coach and derek henry man what's it like
you know you know how tough this game is
you've been on that you've been in a
hole when somebody's coming downhill
what is it like for you to coach a guy
like him mike frable well i mean i've
always respected derek and his ability
to prepare for
for the rigors of the season you know we
we understand
you know the impact that he has on the
game especially our football team
and uh he he prepares for it he knows
what um
you know what lies ahead
and i think he's very determined you
know but you know it's always fun you
know i mean he we try to you know
protect him sometimes against him
himself and work out a routine and a
schedule and what we feel like is best
for him but you know he would go every
single day at practice if that's what we
wanted him to do and
you know that that's not that's not his
plan but um he is always ready for for
as many carries and and he wants the
ball as many times as he can get when
you were when you were uh playing who
was the guy coming through the hole you
wanted to see the lease well probably
jerome you know probably busty bussy was
you know i i
crossed over with him in pittsburgh
right and i went away and you know i'd
played them in years to follow and
you know no i'm like oh it's actually
really live this isn't just like tag off
days when we were teammates now it's
actually we have to try to tackle this
guy
and he would deliver
you
well yeah certainly he just wanted to
try to get him before he got it going
man oh man i just remember those days
for sure too i remember he trucked
urlacher one year and he just
he kind of seemed around and that's
another thing too that i love about
derrick henry is he seems to relish it
he seems to like the trucking part of it
he likes the fourth quarter in a
different player different different
body style different play style but
right you know certainly very unique in
their own right and uh very very um
you know productive mike frable here on
the rich eisen show
how pretty you just use the word
productive how productive is it for you
to take a look at the the film against
cincinnati um and what do you take out
of that at all well we watch you know we
watch every game that we play we go
through them all we go through all the
cut ups and
you know like like a lot of gay or every
game you know we we know that there's
going to be a lot of good in there
there's going to be a
handful of bad and there's going to be
some of those things that we have to
that are going to get you beat and
turning the ball over
and giving up big plays are one you know
basically at the top of the hit chart
for us and so
you know we turned the ball over
offensively
uh we gave up a you know a big play
early you know to jamar we dove and
you know missed a tackle there on a
quick pass that a change field position
and so you know we take it we try to
take as much out of every game as we
possibly can
and uh what do you say to those who say
it's your quarterback's fault
i'm sure you hear it
yeah i mean i think that's the easy
answer you know i mean i think that
there's a
there's a lot that goes into it you know
ryan knows he has to take care of
football but but everybody else knows
that they have a job to do to
to provide uh you know a clean pocket
you know we got to run great routes and
we have to go
you know catch the football in front of
our eyes and
those are all three and brian's got to
make great decisions so
those ultimately are what leads the
interceptions not just specifically in
that game but you know when you turn the
football over you fumble it chances are
you know it's loose you're switching
hands or you're going to stiff arm and
the ball gets outside the framework of
your body and the second guy coming in
and you know so there's all ways that we
can protect that guy who has the ball
he's got a he's got a responsibility but
everybody else has a responsibility as
well to protect them and the other two
narratives about their about your team
um or at least your team is is is
associated with
is the fact of russell wilson is now in
the
um
conference and
matt ryan is now in the conference and
um you also have
desean watson returning to the
conference and the americans trying to
figure out how that narrative affects
the tennessee titans
yeah well the the narrative is is that
you were the first overall seed and the
conference just got even even
more difficult
national football league it's hard we
played
however many teams eight or nine teams
that made the playoffs last year
and beat however many of them it's gonna
be the same next year you know it's
everybody's got 220 million to spend and
it's gonna be great players on every
team that that's why this game is great
that's why this league is great that's
why everybody loves it
18 teams have a chance to to make the
playoffs or how many did last year 20
some teams
56 games within the last two minutes are
decided 31 on the last play like
take your heart pills and and buckle up
mike frable here on the rich eisen show
um i mean like you guys you know i mean
you guys you guys have been around this
league forever yeah you just it's what
it's like no i know that and and so and
again you know and i love it
[Applause]
you love the competition of it i and and
i get it i i absolutely get it that's
why i wanted to ask you that question
mike frable you know i knew i'd get an
answer similar to that but i just wanted
to hear it from your mouth um the uh
you're just dragging on i really had to
just answer the question well i'm a
michigan man i like to hear myself talk
mike come on now you understand me you
know was it
is there is is this like baseball is
like a pitch clock am i on a pitch clock
right now with you is that the way it
works opening day today huh
yes
there is that too uh is aj brown on the
on the on the trade block
mike as long as i'm the head coach i i
love aj professionally personally
um
you know i've been
i've gotten him to to know him well as
his coach and
uh enjoy
seeing him as much as i possibly can so
you know saw him here working out here
earlier um
said hi so you know as long as i'm the
coach here i would i would want to have
aj brown on my football team mike vrabel
here on the rich eisen show in the
couple minutes i have left with you i'm
i want to pick your brain here because
i'm sure you know all these scenarios
since you forwarded an idea to fix over
time to the membership at the um league
meeting that just finished up
last month you wanted uh teams to or
suggested teams to go for two if they
scored touchdown to win it instead uh it
was i guess more of a uh just a a more
conventional if you will idea uh yeah so
my question for you right before mine
got zero votes i tried to pull it off
but they wouldn't let me
that's the that's the way these things
work so
um right you can't fire me i quit
so let's get into it here um
do you are you now gonna go um and and
give the ball up in overtime you want
you want it second you want it first now
under these new yeah i mean i think
those are things analytically we'll look
at and and i and i know that that's
you know been been the idea um
and i think that that's obviously you
know exactly what you're going to need
you're going to have you know
most likely if you're you know are down
you're going to have four downs to do it
and
you know that would be
i'm sure the analytical approach and
you know and then there's probably also
the approach that says hey man we want
to go score and we want to put the
pressure on them and
you know so i'm sure we'll look at all
those things um you know when the
playoffs come around
uh next year what's your general sense
though i mean i'm just interested in
gaming it out unless you you don't want
i mean i just try to go through the
general sense was that if you if you
defer and you play defense right no i
know the f but what do you prefer what
do you [ __ ] have to make that
decision we don't the playoffs aren't
for
quite a while
no i know that but i mean you gotta i
mean you gotta be prepared don't you
think i mean this is yeah i'm not gonna
prepare for a game that i don't know who
we're playing or where we're playing at
so it really is all circumstantially
based is what you're saying well you
could you could have a you could have a
big rainstorm coming in and and it could
be a torrential downpour and you'd want
to take the football and scores humanly
as fast as possible because
you know you knew that the rain rain was
coming i you know there's a lot of
factors that go into it you know
we'll we'll look at it and we'll try to
be ready that uh you know when the
playoffs come around next year what
about the idea that you prefer to know
uh what you have to do offensively that
the team that gets it second will have
the benefit of knowing that and have to
go for all four down go on every single
fourth down right i mean that's what we
touched on right that was what that was
would be in the analytical approach i
know i need a field goal i know i need a
touchdown
um and i'm going to use all four downs
to get it it's a tie game you know i
still have to protect the the the
football field position all those things
you know i think all that comes in to
tend to play but at the end of the day i
think it's important that you know with
the investment that teams are making to
quarterbacks
that
you know those premier players are you
know gonna have an opportunity to have
an impact on the game if it were to go
to overtime what would you like about
your idea what did you like about that
you know i i thought that it gave a
little bit of validation instead of
having a walk-off that you had to
validate you know i
used to watch the old skins game with my
grandpa and you know if you made a
birdie you'd have to validate and at
least make a par on the next holder to
win all the cash and so i thought that
that would be
a way to validate it uh if there were a
long penalty a long pass play
long touchdown somebody falls falls down
or something and
you know maybe a team was going to go
for two didn't get it fifty percent of
the time you know they could ultimately
end up losing the game
uh
if you opted to kick the extra point
then the other team would get the ball
so it had a little bit of intrigue and
my our guess was that
75 percent of the time that the other
team was going to get it but in the end
it couldn't guarantee that they would
well i didn't run into you on the the
night of honors uh coach mike verbal but
congratulations on on the award uh so
well earned and richly deserved who'd
you who did you hear from that night
a lot of people you know i mean just
coaches friends family you know just uh
players
um
it's a great honor you know it's an
honor and privilege to have played in
this game and
have the opportunity to coach in it
and uh
you know it's you're a good coach
because you have great players and
that's what it comes down to so um do
you hear from belichick here from bill
that night i mean i obviously heard from
bill but not in that in that regard he
he wasn't he wasn't on the inbox i don't
think that meant
he wasn't tuned in nfl honors is that
what you're saying
oh coach mike vrabel i appreciate the
time thanks very much always guys thank
you so much no you got it man thanks for
the time and we'll see you down the road
thank you you got it that's mike frable
everybody coach mike frable he doesn't
like long winding uh windups i'm i'm
very ponderous
he wasn't is he was he
he's all business he's busting my balls
on how ponderous i was is that what that
was i think that's also an ohio state
mission no it's not i think he's no it's
not you know i think he gives it to you
because he knows
that what that i can take it
and that you end that you got them this
year i kind of appreciate that how many
interviewers is he interrupting saying
how does this how is this pertinent to
me
we're at kansas city you guys just came
from
he's basically telling you it's cold by
the way what do you do that was a
belichick in him right there like of
course there's so many different
circumstances
you know big rainstorms coming i'm not
giving the ball up i'm trying to score
you [ __ ]
what are we supposed to do you [ __ ]
you know what else i would like to play
i appreciate it by the way i don't know
if that's the new yorker me i kind of
appreciate that straightforwardness
right there hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here